wir haben mal sehen ich jedenfalls etwas
worüber ich mich heute gefreut haben und
zwar über wolfgang kupke geht er heute
ein bemerkenswertes interview gegeben
hat und bemerkenswerte dinge gesagt hat
nämlich was man machen soll wenn man
keine regeln unsinnig findet und da der
mann politiker ist und auch noch
stellvertretender parlamentspräsident
hat sein wort gewicht hören sie mal zu
es gibt dazu auch wir hatten hier einen
stand wie in jedem ort den ich kenne
ganz prohibition scanner also knallten
die trotzdem geöffnet hatten obwohl es
verboten werden sie mal rein herrscht ja
selbstverständlich was denn sonst wir
haben hier keinen einzigen fall in
strande mich also war illegalen büro das
fahrrad ist eigentlich nicht gewohnt ist
sondern es haben sich leute schlicht und
ergreifend auch an den stammtischen
getroffen obwohl es verboten weil sie
weil sie gesagt haben hier ist nichts
sie ist keine wir haben hotspots in kiel
in gaarden und mettenhof schick sie hat
nicht einen einzigen fall gehabt hier
nehmen aber was wird dann gewesen dann
muss ich gestehen wir das fass ist voll
von kumpel kita jeder kennt ihn was wäre
denn wenn der dorfpolizist lang gelaufen
wäre und gesagt hätte mensch der sitzt
doch genau das ist ja damit bestimmen an
dem abend selbstverständlich
war jetzt ist also offiziell unsinnige
corona regeln müssen wir nicht befolgen
das ist ein richtig starkes statement
über das ich mich wirklich gefreut hab'
weil es sagt auch hört auf ihr politiker
uns mit nonsens gesetzen und
verordnungen wie gegen den gesunden
menschenverstand gehen gegen die
lebenserfahrung gegen das eigene
verständnis von einem gesunden sicheren
leben hört auf uns damit zu gängeln und
es heißt auch in die andere richtung
kommt leute lasst uns jetzt endlich
endlich endlich locker machen und diese
angst überwinden das corona uns alle
dahin grafen wird ich möchte szenen
sehen im fußballstadion in hamburg
sollte es wieder gehen demnächst wohl
leute sich in den armen liegen und
feiern ich möchte auch dass teenager
ihren ersten kuss und von mir aus mit
zunge erleben und nicht denken jetzt
muss oma und opa sterben deshalb ich
möchte dass wir endlich wieder zu einem
normalen leben zurückkehren und deshalb
bin ich wolfgang kubicki wirklich sehr
sehr sehr sehr dankbar das war ein
aufruf zur cola entspannungs politik
aber ich würde die kubicki das war toll
aber da sei es kein politiker da saß ein
typ und der hat heute der kriegt doch
der 1 schied dort nach dem anderen der
macht doch alles kaputt was die korona
beauftragten in den ganzen jahren ganzen
monat mit einer nuller incident ja kein
kranker kein infizierter und die leute
sollten sich aber nicht treffen also ich
meine damit das war damals
trinkt mit der polizei zu dem fest
aber die die haltung die daraus finde
ich glaube
ja ja das ist gelangt der liberale ist
wo er na gut da ist immer auch so eine
art pippi langstrumpf der deutschen
politik das muss man auch sagen da gibt
es ja auch den bewussten bruch des
kongos bei ihm das macht sie auch so
erfrischend weil er wenn er den kommen
bricht dass er uns allen den spiegel
vorher genau wie pippi langstrumpf das
getan hat und er hat ja auch eine lust
daran also insofern wird gar nicht
verhauen von politisch korrekten soll
alle wissen kubicki darf dass das ist
teil seiner politischen rhetorik und
natürlich muss man ihm dankbar sein dass
er diese diese angst fassaden einfach
mal live um stößt aber ich finde das
kann man auch durchaus in eine
ernsthafte frage klein nämlich wie lange
soll der staat noch die leute bevor
unten wie lange soll er ihnen quasi die
verantwortung abnehmen und wann wird es
zeit dass jeder wieder in seine
eigenverantwortung zurückkehrt es weiß
doch jetzt jeder
die man sich schützen kann das was ich
im kann und wenn jemand sich nicht dem
zuletzt okay das ist dann irgendwann
einmal auf eigenes risiko
ich bin dafür dass in absehbarer zeit
all diese krone regen bei uns wirklich
abgeschafft haben ja und ich finde es
ist wenn wir schon beim ernsthaften hat
auch noch ein anderer punkt je mehr
erkennbar unsinnige regeln der staat
lässt desto weniger menschen werden auch
in die sinnvollen glauben also sozusagen
befolgt oder sich daran gehalten wird ja
nur wenn die regel von einer absoluten
mehrheit der menschen als sinnvoll
erachtet wird und wenn sie das nicht
mehr sind und viele der chor ohne regeln
waren extrem zweifelhafte ich mir noch
in hamburg um die alster gejobbt
natürlich ohne maske als dort masken
pflicht warten weil ich finde als beim
joggen an der frischen luft wo weit und
breit kein anderer mensch ist ja
das hab ich das
alles wird also das habe ich damals auch
bei twitter verbreitet und die reaktion
war es sozusagen entsprechend twitter
hat überprüft ob sie mich sperren und
haben mich dann auch geschehen ist ist
ein quasi aufruf war zum zivilcourage ja
ich kann nur sagen bei uns sinnlichen
regeln brauchen wir zivilen ungehorsam
um ein denkmal im wahrsten sinne des
wortes ein denkmal nach so haben was
wird da in letzter zeit eigentlich alles
mitgemacht haben und was wir uns alles
haben auch bieten lassen mit einer
mehrheitsmeinung im rücken und das finde
ich da haben wir alle im großen auftrag
wie mehrheit die viele dieser unsinnigen
kroner regeln mitgetragen hat davon zu
überzeugen dass sie unsinnig waren und
dass wir in der zukunft sozusagen nicht
nochmal in so eine situation laufen das
macht mehr da ist es weder wirklich
sorge
vielleicht nicht ich muss auch ja weil
ich da gerade
der umgang mit risiken ja die mentalität
risiko möglichst auszuschließen und die
vorstellung dass der staat
seinen bürgern jedes lebens risiko
abnimmt wir sind für unsere
lebensrisiken als bürger auch selbst
selbst verantwortlich es kann sein dass
es und notlagen gibt wie diese pandemie
am anfang ja aber irgendwann mal jetzt
wird dann impfquote von irgendwann
einmal 30 63 75 prozent ja
glaube ich ist es ist es nicht mehr
gerechtfertigt so einen ausnahmezustand
der abstand aber ich finde das ja diese
im nachgang diese auseinandersetzung mit
der pandemie verordnungs lage und gesetz
geben wirklich arme innehalten lassen
mussten was was da geschehen ist und
wofür der staat eigentlich zuständig
sind meiner in meiner vorstellungswelt
ist der staat zuständig für vorsorge für
erklärungen und aufklärung und dann
ehrlich gesagt nur noch für die logistik
also wenn 2000 leute an einer krankheit
erkranken und auf eine intensivstation
kommen dann hat der staat dafür zu
sorgen dass 2000 in metten da sind um
die menschen versorgt werden alles an
eine einmischung in
privatangelegenheiten die mich von
anfang an in dieser pandemie total
gestört hat auch wenn ich zugeben muss
dass ich auf phasen hatte wo ich gedacht
habe vielleicht bin ich mit dieser
radikalen liberalen thesen da am schluss
bei denen dabei die bedauern müssen
heute sehe ich muss ich gar nicht
sondern es war sozusagen übertrieben es
war ein übertriebener eingriff in
freiheit fern und das müssen beim
nächsten mal vielleicht auch mit anderen
themen ganz anders machen was ist denn
wenn einer plötzlich auf die idee kommt
und sagt wir müssen ja die klimaziele
ich ja am liebsten deshalb natürlich
ausgangssperre ab 22 uhr weil anders als
bei corona das sterben nur ein paar
leute ich war einfach er ist jetzt beim
klima sterben wir alle also bleiben ab
21 uhr zu hause wenn das kommt darf es
nicht mehr sein dass man den parlamenten
vorbei entschieden wird und wir dann zu
hause hocken und denken wenn ich jetzt
ausgebildeten verbrechen kann man sagen
ein pandemie ist so eine herausragend
einmaliges ereignis und es war noch so
viele tote da würde ich die die
etatisten noch entschuldigen dass ich es
übertrieben haben die frage ist nur wann
kommen sie wieder raus welcher
wenn der staat sich erklärt zur super
nanny eines eine eine
gesundheitsfürsorge dann landen wir
bekommen
die wirklich
mitarbeiter müssen nicht mehr wenn sie
doppelt geben sie mit einer maske über
den gang laufen nein selbst mir noch ein
mitarbeiter ein und das erwarte ich mir
es ist dennoch so mitarbeiter die
doppelt geimpft sind also wirklich ich
würde mir wünschen und wir brauchen mal
wieder stark unternehmer die sagen jetzt
reicht's bei mir ist ab heute keine
masken pflichten
er selbst sage ich nehme die maus gibt
nicht ab aber sollte in der unternehmen
ein freedom day geben dass jeder selbst
entscheiden kann die die tragen wollen
sollen sie doch tragen das ist ja auch
freiheit jeder kann für sich selbst
entscheiden aber ich würde mir wünschen
wirklich dass unternehmer sich hinstellt
und für ihre unternehmen den film day
ausrufen er in 1 unternehmen ist einfach
schon mal machen und dann zivile
ungehorsam gegen den staat auch sind wir
brauchen gerade große unternehmer die
kämpfen wenn ich wirklich der
überzeugung ich und ich würde da
wirklich ich kann dazu nur jeden
aufrufen warum wenn man es möchte meine
40 mann unternehmen hat und man weiß
doch dann voneinander der sgm pfennig
darum sollen diese 40 leute weiterhin
mit maske rummler weil man als
unternehmer ich bin ja eine dann immer
auch fürsorge hat für die menschen und
man kennt die befindlichkeiten die sind
halt unterschiedlichen personen
rücksicht so wie der minister jetzt auch
reden und das saßen dann die
fürsorglichen in einem boot
[Musik]